what up guys welcome back to another
episode of get close
i'm your host bart kwan
and i'm your co-host gio and today we
got a nba legend in the house yes jason
richardson yes
14 seasons in the nba
uh one
the second person to do to win the dunk
contest back to back
i'm not even quite sure who that first
person is no one really no one cares no
one knows no one cares what's that
champion
and um it's crazy to
you're the first like pro super high
level athlete
that uh we've actually had on this
podcast i'm honored yeah we're honestly
honored now thank you so i just have so
many questions i'm just so interested um
so i guess i'll start with the first one
is
when did you know you wanted to play in
the nba oh geez um
it's funny because the story about the
nba is i always wanted to dunk i was
really big in a dunk contest so oh okay
growing up i always watched the dunk
contest on saturday that was the thing i
wanted to do
and i didn't even know that was part of
the nba so i
actually wanted to be the dunk contest
before the nba so um you know it's
amazing i think i always wanted to be a
basketball player but the nba i think
for me um it was probably like the
second or third grade i knew that's what
i wanted to do was just love her
basketball wait so you were dunking
before the second afternoon no no no i
wasn't done before that i used to like
had a little play rooms around the house
and yeah
you know back then we used to put a
hanger on the door and a pair of socks
and just imitate what the ducks were
seeing so um but you know
once i start dunking i start dunking
like the ninth grade okay i knew that's
what i wanted to do wow dang in the
ninth grade that's amazing when did you
know you were a badass like when did you
know you were like i am the [ __ ]
i'm a little bit better than everyone
around me yeah basically um i think
around like
um ninth grade um i got my first dunk in
in high school um and then i started
doing 360s and games i started dunking
on people
and uh i kind of realized then that you
know i was pretty good and then you know
for me i didn't grow up with much i came
from you know warfare system my mom had
six kids um it was tough for us but you
know that ninth grade year i kind of
felt like i was starting to get good and
every year i would tell her mom when i
get older don't buy your house i'm gonna
make it today
and so every year my mom you know she
wasn't the type of parents like yeah
whatever she's like okay
but every year she's like man i got five
other kids telling me the same [ __ ] no
not really it's like every year
i could hear in her turn that she
started believing me more and more every
year i could start hearing that because
i started getting better and better i
started getting college letters i
started getting recruited and stuff like
that so i could hear in her voice every
year like okay okay and then like by my
you know the time is for me to go to nba
she's like okay i'm ready for my house
that's awesome you know when you're like
so
i think all kids got dreams right so
when i was little uh my dad used to love
watching like war movies so i didn't
even know what it was called but as a
kid i was like i want to be army man and
i just thought army man meant you're
just crawling around in brushes all day
right not knowing like wars or whatever
any of that stuff i just want to be
crawling in bushes
so when you're in second and third grade
um finding your passion for basketball
did you know or were you put on a
specific program because kids these days
oh geez it's like it's almost like uh
you know some kids get scouted i've seen
like kids play baseball and it's
televised on espn when they're 11 years
old like
you don't just get there by luck you
know like in your when you were coming
up did you have a program or a set
schedule or a trajectory none of that i
mean i tell people all the time i
actually grew up playing hockey
uh being from michigan oh okay
i played hockey into the eighth grade
until my feet got too big for skates and
back then
there was no such thing as custom skates
yeah yeah and so i played hockey
football baseball and ran track and i
played all the sports all the way up to
my junior in high school so there was no
such thing as specialized sports back
then you just played whatever your
friends played wait how did your mom do
like were you like in a like on a team
and your mom took you and all of the
five kids like to do this well i was
from a small town where everybody know
everybody and uh i mean back then we all
used to hype on our bikes and ride to
you know 10 miles on our bikes with all
our friends so
it was like a community raising each
other if i had to be somewhere i just
hop in with one of my friends and if it
was my mom's turn she did it and took a
whole bunch of kids so uh it was always
it was all over the place and it wasn't
everything was really far like i said we
just we didn't play a lot of all-state
tournaments everything was local or our
friday's tournament from kids when we
were in middle school is detroit which
is like a two-hour drive south from
where i was
wow that's so you just played everything
and it wasn't until freshman year you're
like oh i think basketball's starting to
shine i'm gonna specialize yeah yeah it
wasn't really specialized i still play
football i still play baseball and all
those sports until my junior year and
like so my junior year is when i started
getting the big college offers you know
michigan michigan state ucla
um
i got every school besides kentucky no
every school besides duke in north
carolina it still bothers me to this day
but um that's when i realized that you
know i was going to school to play
basketball and it didn't make sense to
go play football and get hurt or
baseball be burnt out so
that's when i
specialize in my sport my junior year
but um it's just crazy because you see a
lot of kids now they have trainers at
five or six years old and i'm like this
is crazy i didn't have a training until
i got to the nba
so um it's just a different era of what
goes on now yeah i went to ucla and uh
russell westbrook was in one of my
classes
and in the summer he would hold like
summer camps and stuff and you would see
the five-year-olds and i'm like damn
it's crazy people are putting their kids
in super young but i also feel like the
the game now or like just the uh
pipeline is so sophisticated yeah you
can't afford to lose like maximizing
each phase of it yeah and and that's the
biggest thing it's a it's a real fine
line on
you know borderline pushing your kids
and your kids wanted to do that yeah me
growing up i didn't want to
you know if i didn't want to go to the
gym i didn't go to the gym but i wanted
to do it on my own it was nobody dragged
me into the gym like you got to go work
out you got to go do this they just it
was just natural to me i'm just a
natural person that like to get up in
the morning work out because
i knew the nba was my dream but i also
knew the numbers are making it to the
nba it's only like 443 spots and as i'm
making it is like in the lottery so wow
i was like i got to be one of those 443
people you know to get into that spot so
i was sacrificing stuff on my own
because that was my past how how did you
know to do the math like that because a
lot of people i don't think they do
the math you know like even if people go
i want to be an astronaut they don't go
oh wait there's only maybe like five
astronauts a year or something and i
gotta like really make myself
competitive like how did you even know
to do the math yeah you don't even have
access to like the internet to like
really see what's popping off you know
you know i just did the numbers on that
and you know when i went to cancer i got
a little bit older in like middle school
you started hearing the numbers you
start hearing about how many high school
players go to college and so you started
doing the math he's like wow you know
getting there is really hard so what do
i have to do to get there and it drove
it almost became like a borderline
obsession that i had within me like
if i'm sleeping somebody is working out
wow
and it was just it was just in me and to
this day i'm still like that i feel like
if i'm sleeping somebody's all working
me right now wow but that was my path
because that's what i wanted to do and
that was my dream and so i knew i had to
figure out a way to do it and that's and
it was guys way more talented than me on
my high school team it was i had two
guys that should have been pros but the
stars line for me and i hit the lottery
wow i'm not sure if you hit the lottery
for sure it's not like that but like
where did that come from like was your
mom like were your parents or like were
there any other people in your life that
were like constantly trying to like
remind you of like what your path is no
it wasn't a constant reminder it was
like my grandfather he was a hard worker
he was the type person to get up at four
in the morning
go work on the fields in the yard and he
had like chicken and pigs coming from
the country
and he had all these things he just
liked the work and constantly kept
himself busy and um i think it was just
seeing him when i was younger that kind
of gave me that work ethic of just
always working working working are your
brothers and sisters like that too no
they were watching a different grandpa
in this crazy because my brothers and
sisters were super athletic and super
skilled i had a brother that jumped
higher than me and he said what
and it was just amazing like they just
it wasn't their thing and i was just
uber focused on what i want i knew what
i wanted out of life
they just
i mean they just didn't want that part
what number out of the six are you i'm
in the middle child and it sucks i don't
know
it sucks and i remember my mom all the
time about it being the middle child
because
like i got two older brothers and
sisters and then it's me but then
there's twins right under me and the
toughest part about that was my birthday
is january 20th yeah their birthday is
january 22nd and so
i always shared a birthday with you yeah
so
i still feel that to this day like and
those two shout outs
yeah i'm like my birthday january 22nd
because that's when i always celebrated
my birthday was with there so
you're not the oldest boy no you're also
not the oldest girl and you're not the
baby you know i just feel right there
yeah i'm also a middle child so i know
what you're talking about
what i've seen though is a lot of like
middle child i don't know what it is
there's an additional drive you know
like i see it from you i see it from
here i see from a lot of my other
friends because i think like the first
kid you know they get like preferred
treatment then the baby gets like the
spoil treatment and then i feel like
somewhere in the middle kind of gets
lost and we're the forgotten ones yeah
i don't know something about that
makes the middle child like wanna
achieve extra hard oh yeah we want the
attention yeah maybe i think that's what
it is
um or it's it's one of those where it's
like well damn i see what they're doing
and they [ __ ] up and i'm seeing what
they're doing and i don't like that so
then i think we kind of take from both
and we're like okay let's let's do our
own thing right so you have kids uh that
play basketball too
and you knowing what it takes to get to
the highest level because this is
something that i struggle with as a
parent too like especially my kids only
four so i want to push him
but i also don't want to make him like
doing two hours with the push-ups
i want to push him hard but i also want
him to fall in love with it i hate it
so like how do you find
the fine line
and like to to parent them in the right
way you know because it's their journey
it's their path um me personally i wish
none of my kids played basketball really
why
because there's just so much to the
world out there and but i think the way
i i
kind of combat that a little bit is make
sure that we're around the kids like uh
my boys for example i have three kids my
daughter's 22 my boys are 16 to 14. um
daughter little old so she's out there
too late for already college basketball
she plays basketball d2 college
basketball
um she does a lot of things but she's
you know she's a young adult yeah she's
trying throughout the world but yeah
well my boys um you know they're
well-rounded um
they both speak you know two languages
spanish and a little bit of mandarin wow
yeah
they uh play instruments i'm gonna start
speaking to mandarin yeah they'll know
what they're talking about seriously um
they play instruments uh you know one
play piano one played the violin um
they're all a students so um i just
didn't want them just to be athletes
because i know how that feeling was
because i grew up like that and oh
you're a dumb jock dumb jock but
i wasn't that dumb jock i just was never
pushed to you know
see as an education and yeah and that
that's a big part of it so for me i've
kind of pushed him in that area but
sports that's just the cherry on top for
me like go have fun love it
and and enjoy it because i'm not going
to push you it's just was there ever a
moment where like the kids were just
like oh man this is hard i wanna i don't
wanna do this anymore and then what how
did you respond with that no it was
never a moment like that um i think in
this era they have a lot of selfishness
so i have moments with them where it's
like man nobody pass me the ball
so it's like well go get the ball go get
a rebound go get a steal go play defense
um so i just try to keep them positive
in that way but
um they're both pretty good players and
you know playing basketball something
they want to do and i remind them every
now and then like it's hard what you're
doing you know trying to get to the
level that you guys want to do
like you really have to sacrifice and
really push yourself but guess what i'm
not going to do it you got to want to do
that on your own yeah that's amazing
parenting i love that
seeing like um
you know like
it almost seems like when you're your
father is great right it's hard
for
kids to fill those shoes like even with
like michael jordan
i forgot what his
[Laughter]
then skin were actually pretty good
basketball
yeah it just you know when you're at
that level i mean for my boys they get a
little bit but not like a lebron or
michael jordan um everybody expects you
to be your parent and they expect you to
be that and that's just not the case i
mean i think it's kind of unfair yeah
it's unfair i think lebron is a really
good player but he's not lebron i think
michael jordan kids were really good
players but they not michael jordan
and for my son he's named after me so
when you see his jason richardson second
uh oh and so they come out there and
expecting to see
a long dangly
dog go crazy
but he's really like he's six three he's
he can dunk and he dunked before i did
he dunked in eighth grade wow but um
he's very skilled like he could shoot
the ball he plays point guard he could
dribble i mean and he knows the game
and i'm like he's way more advanced than
i was i couldn't shoot the ball or
dribble so it's like
he gets a you know he's not his dad you
know he's better than me in my opinion
wow
at that level though do you think
like the game this day like i would i
would watch um
like 19 i don't know 20s basketball
where the only dribbling one
the ball come forwards and backwards and
just going in circles and stuff like the
game evolves right yeah do you think
even though your kid is
technically better than where you were
do you think
he's in a better position than you were
to go to the league
uh i think it's easier for guys um for
me the nba that's
when the kids are on my house
i tell parents that all the time as a
parent my job is to get my kid into
college
um if i could give him a free education
he leaves school debt-free i did my job
but once the kid gets to college it's on
them because are you going to school or
you go party or you go work out
are you going to do your homework or you
go hang out your girlfriend so your
priorities have to line up and there's
no parent in there so for me it's just
to get him to college and i think it's a
little bit easier because it's so much
you know media out there you can watch
videos um you know the college coaches
are even the nba scouts they don't have
to physically be at games now they could
just pull up a video and they could
watch the games live now so
uh it's a little bit easier pass for
those guys to get seen but
it's still hard
so for you you're like as a parent
um my job is up to when you get to
college
i'm gonna do everything i can and in
college
they gotta figure it out they gotta
figure it out i mean cause i went
through it you know my first year in
college i was partying i was happy
a [ __ ] good
and we won the national championship my
first year and
the thing that changed me was getting
towards the end of the season
and our star point guard who was
all-american was going to be a nba
player
i'm walking up my out my uh elevator
going to my dorm room pretty hammered
and
i see my starting point guard
all-american leaving the gym at 11 30 at
night
and i'm like okay i know he's you know a
little bit hurt he's trying to work
himself back in and stuff like that so
i'll go up to him the next day we had a
locker right next to each other i'm like
hey man you know there's 10 cleaves
uh man they got you coming back at 11 30
to get treatment he's like no i'm
working out
it blew my mind like wait a minute me as
a freshman i'm out partying and the star
player of this team is still working
it's still working at 11 30.
partying's done
that day partying's done so
the next year after he was going i was a
sophomore i became a little bit better
player i started
i forced myself to go to the gym at 9 30
at night every night wow so i wouldn't
go on party
and i was leaving the gym 11 30 12
o'clock at night
when you're when you're going in there
um did you have a specific game plan yep
mines was shooting i couldn't shoot so
just work on weekends yeah i had a
machine the shooting machine tossed me
the ball and i get a thousand shots up a
night
wow yeah because i mean i literally
couldn't shoot the ball i could jump but
i couldn't shoot so that was a part of
my plan that i had to work on to get to
the next level i knew my athleticism
wasn't going to last a long time and
and for me i always wanted to try to be
the best player i could possibly be not
the greatest i knew what my skill set
would just give me there or my abilities
but i knew i was good enough to play
against some of the world's best players
and so for me those nights i was going
to the gym late at night i was getting
number shooting and shot shots and i
finally became a shooter
so i know you got you you're saying you
got your work ethic from your grandpa um
but that mindset of like uh working on
your weaknesses and like uh the path you
have to take to make a plan to to
stick to it to like the tenacity and all
like where does that come from
i think that's just me
i just really think that's emmy um i'm
just the type of person is somebody say
i can't do anything i'm gonna try my
best to try to do it and i'm gonna work
my ass off to do it and i'm gonna prove
you wrong i just love doing that so i
think that was i don't even know if
anybody in my family is like that but me
uh but uh i think that's just who i am
what do your uh brothers and sisters do
uh they all working um
like just like nine to five regular jobs
yeah yeah
does it feel
do they is there like how what is the
dynamic you know because i'm sure for
them they're like
my little brother i see them flying all
over the place on tv do they ever like
they're at work like yo that's my little
brother that's my big brother you know
like they're proud of me um you know i
have a close relationship with all of
them i still talk to them all and we you
know we talk weekly and
um are they still all in your hometown
all in michigan um
well my brother actually live out here
you know i just realized
i should go visit
i seriously should go visit him
um but you know we're all close-knit
family i come from a big family like i
said i had six siblings and then my
mother came from 10. wow grandparents
lived together for 64 years before my
grandfather passed and they all i mean
we are a huge family and i was like
doing the math like when my grandmother
passed she passed about seven years
after my grandfather and i was just
doing the math i was like okay it was
ten kids it was 103 grandkids and it was
like oh my gosh
something great grandkids before she
passed away what a beautiful day and
it's like they all live in the same city
so like christmas and thanksgiving
it could literally be like 200 people in
the house that's beautiful you've been
doing math huh yeah
that's crazy that's like half the town
probably yeah yeah
but where i'm from is everybody know
everybody it's about maybe 30 000 40 000
people there so
somebody know more of my family members
and i probably know somebody else their
family members and we just all connected
how cool yeah that's so cool like
talking about the uh like thousand shots
you know that's something that like kobe
is notorious for
um did you play in the area uh the era
of kobe and jordan and if you're able to
see yeah i i actually told a kid this uh
the other day
and lebron too right yeah i'm old enough
to play it against michael jordan
i'm young enough well i'm in the prime
to play against kobe
and i'm young enough to play against
lebron and stuff curry so i feel like my
my my age was like the golden era yeah
yeah yeah yeah i got a little bit of
everything so
um have you been on the same card as
iverson too man i'm saying coors iverson
um
all those guys and i mean i play against
carl malone and wow gary payton but like
i said i played against steph and dame
lillard in lebron that's like the
basketball card
yeah seriously so it's pretty cool but
you know with kobe he was
the the pinnacle of what a two guard was
and so every year once i got to the nba
what's a two car like a shooting guard
okay um
it was like okay i'm working my game to
try to close that gap with colgate that
just never happened but uh for one year
it did um
every
stat that was
written down for two guards shooting
guards i was second to kobe wow it was
just really cool like you know he was
like averaging like 26 points i was
average like 23.
it was like right there and it made me
feel good but i just never had a career
like oh yeah
kobe is kobe but
he was just an amazing player and it
just and was he the last player to go
straight high school no it's it was tons
of right i'll say that but he was
probably probably the most famous most
famous one right most successful one to
come from high school at an nba what was
the what do you think is like the
biggest difference or like the dynamic
on the court
that you feel amongst them you know what
it it's it's levels in the nba yeah
because a lot of people are like oh i'll
probably go out there no you can't not
like some guys out there there's just
like
there's superstars and he was a
superstar and it was whatever you did
you just couldn't stop him
and so
if kobe
you can't just like move to the side
yeah you can't do anything
you can't
trust me we double teamed this guy
before and he still was making shots
so for him it was just like
if he averaged 28 points he's going to
get 28 points there's nothing you can't
do about it
he's just that good
did you play uh because you know there's
that other famous game in the last dance
where like jordan had a fever
and he's like screw it i'ma come back
and he just goes crazy have you felt
that presence on the court
for myself yeah yeah from him like that
kind of energy for kobe yeah yes i have
um we was in the western conference
finals and you know we were down i'm in
phoenix and he just went crazy on us i
mean like we couldn't stop him yeah and
then the thing was it about it when i
knew like in my opinion michael jordan
is the best player ever played a game
i knew kobe was second he hits this shot
he's falling out of bounds the shot
clock is going down he shoots the shot
he hits it and he's while he's falling
he slapped our coach on ass and ran down
the court
i was like ah this guy is amazing this
guy is the best player i ever played
against down the floor awesome oh my god
it was just that amazing though man and
just and we knew like once he hit that
shot i was like we look we lost this
game and we still had like three minutes
left and we were down like 10 points but
he was at a level so high
that it was just like he let you know
like you're beneath me and there's
nothing we could do about it
damn yeah okay so kind of going back um
bart's been hugging up i've been hugging
you up this whole time
i know like literally my mouth goes like
this and i'm like
and then bart jumps in but um how was it
playing like professionally like your
first game how was that like what were
you
yeah that was amazing um because our
first game we had a preseason game we're
in hawaii
uh playing against the lakers
and they finally subbed me in and my
teammate gilbert arenas played a
long-time nba
oh i had his basketball shoes yeah
yeah yeah and um
he walks up to me he's like yo
there goes shaq i was like hey they go
kobe and we just like giggling like
little kids
it's so
it was like my first moment that i
actually made it to nba and realized i
made it to my dream that is beautiful
isn't that crazy are you at this point i
was 20. oh
that was beautiful how does it feel to
like
because technically they're the enemy
right
to go i'm a fan of them you have to keep
it inside like i'm ultra competitive i
hate losing that anything yeah i i don't
if i'm playing against a little kid i'm
winning
and that's not just basketball pool i
mean whatever anything that's
competitive
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you know i played against some some guys
i i was invited to play against the
olympic team that went to australia
which was like vince carter gary payton
jason kidd
ray allen wow and you know we go out
there the whole week they're literally
talking [ __ ] to us we a whole bunch of
college kids
these guys gonna be hall of famers and
they literally trash and that's the
whole week
like i couldn't get a shot off i
couldn't make it a shot you got you're
just brought there to help warm them up
we we had a training camp we we
practiced against the mogs training camp
and then we had an exhibition game at
the end of the training camp
and like for three days they just like
literally was talking trash to us
pushing us around we're college kids i
love it so we get to the exhibition game
in front of the fans
i go out there and i'm like the whole
week i'm pissed off i didn't want to
talk to any of those guys because they
literally
every name under the sun they calling us
that's awesome and so we go out there
and i'm like you know what [ __ ] these
guys
and so i didn't shake their heads and i
go out there and i have a really good
game i scored like 19 points in the
first half
but then the point is after the game i
was taking pictures with all those guys
i get a picture with you
with you but that's just how you keep it
in you just you know
when you're in between those lines if
you don't have the same jersey on
you're sticking with those guys but
after that everybody's really cool with
each other it's a fraternity like i said
it's only you know 430 some guys yeah so
everybody knows everybody you either
play with them or you played against
them or you somehow had the same coach
or something so it's a fraternity yeah
this podcast is brought to you by
ziprecruiter okay so according to the
latest research 90 of employers plan to
make enhancing the employee experience a
top priority in 2022
after all
a happy workplace is key to attracting
and keeping great employees i know with
some of the companies that we've had and
currently have it really is about
catering to your staff to your team
um you make them feel valued you make
them feel hurt you make them feel seen
and you make them feel like they're
actually contributing to this bigger
picture aka your company goal or just
your company y
so why not
invest more time into really
appreciating and focusing and helping
elevate your team
so since that is the case
this is where zip recruiter comes in
i've used zip recruiter multiple times
and i absolutely love it from an
employer perspective um as you know i
own a few small businesses
and i've said this time and time again
owning a small business is like flying a
plane while fixing it at the same time
so you're constantly wearing
a million hats and you know one one of
them is hr unfortunately for us
sometimes we're spread a little too thin
we don't have you know the the ample
amount of time to go through
and post
uh our job listing everywhere and then
go through a ton of resumes so i am so
so so grateful that zip ziprecruiter
exists because i put out my job post one
time and then ziprecruiter does its
algorithm thing where it searches
through all these potential candidates
looking for the keywords that pertain to
your particular job and then they start
sending you matches and it is the best
ever
not only is it like the best because it
does that algorithm thing where it
matches all these keywords for the job
that you're specifically trying to hire
for it is the best because it gives you
the option to look through every single
resume and read it from beginning to end
or it does this quick valuation where
you can kind of skim through it see the
key things that you need you can thumbs
it up thumbs it down or like thumbs it
in the middle i guess if you're unaware
or unsure i should say if you want to
move further with this application or
applicant
um and that has been by far my favorite
feature okay my second favorite feature
with ziprecruiter
because yeah i don't have time to like
go through all of this stuff so the fact
that i can quickly rate no no no yes yes
yes maybe maybe and then i go through it
and then i thoroughly read everything is
my favorite most absolute favorite
feature okay second but i did say that
um the first one is the fact that i
don't have to post in a million places
and then look for and hunt down a bunch
um okay so it's my second i'll i'll fix
that
um
but for everyone listening right now
please please please especially if
you're trying to hire or if you're
trying to be hired i'm speaking from an
employer perspective but from an
employee perspective i highly recommend
you posting your resume on there because
again the algorithm it is the best so
for everyone listening right now it's
time to find the right employees or
employer uh for your workplace um or
your new job so
you're gonna get it for free at this
exclusive website okay it's going to be
ziprecruiter.com
get close that's the only way that
you're going to get this for free is by
visiting ziprecruiter.com
get close
ziprecruiter.com get close
vince carter is like one of the dunk oh
geez yeah did you get a chance to dunk
on him no
no i didn't uh vince is actually awesome
man he's like a big brother every time
i've seen him
he's always cool
everybody always say what happened with
you and him getting a dunk contest i
tell him all the time he's winning i'm
not gonna lie he's he's a better dunker
than me he has like a lot of like crazy
skills but uh he's just a great guy
that's crazy because like you know when
the only televised game is like the nba
right but then you always hear
um like the side stories of like the
other leagues like like is it like
droolie or d lee or g-league g-league no
so there's a bunch of other leagues that
people drop out try to get back in
what's that whole system like i don't
quite understand but i hear it all the
time and then you'll see like summer
practice or whatever and a guy kills
he's back in the the main league again
like what is that whole system it's just
like a farm system um so in baseball
they they took it from baseball so
baseball you have i think it's triple a
which is their minor league it's trying
to prep those guys to get ready to go to
the major leagues
um some of those guys just not good
enough to get there yet yeah or it might
be a guy that's
in the nba and he's coming off an injury
so they put him down to get you know
back in shape or just a young guy that
got drafted that needed more playing
time and he's not ready to play in the
nba and they put him down so it's just a
basically a minor league system to help
guys prepare to get him to get to that
level to play in the nba do they get
paid at that level yeah they do they get
paid um fairly decent is it the same
teams is it like like lakers and then
laker
oh like i don't know g league or is it a
whole nother los angeles ponders or
something but it's it's uh
i don't know it is some crazy names like
that seriously
um it's team affiliated i think um out
of the was 30 nba teams i think 26 or 27
have affiliated g league team minor
league teams um so they report to those
guys so
for instance you might get a guy that
got drafted in the second round
um that they think he can be an nba
player but he's not an nba player right
now so they'll sign him to a minor
league contract which they call a
two-way contract where if we want to
pull them up for the nba just to have
them on the bench we can but we go stick
them down in the minor leagues so um
that's how the team's affiliated with
the minor league teams
so he doesn't know about this he didn't
do any of that
he's guessing here hell
he's just like pulling it out of his
butt
he's part of the system right
because like people that are really i
think big fans they like like the first
time i ever came across it was uh
uh so
in my community jeremy lin's are michael
jordan
even though he's not that good but the
first time i ever uh read about him was
he pulled up against john wall and
scored like 20 points on him in the
non-mba i'm like man not even real and
then i started reading about it and i'm
like oh there's like another
developmental league and i just didn't
really understand what that whole system
was you know the cool thing about jeremy
lin was he he took the nba by storm i
mean this kid just literally came out of
nowhere was sleeping on somebody couch
yeah played at harvard harvard
ballers at harvard
that's probably why he went there but i
mean he came i mean he came and took the
lead by storm and it was just
it was like one of the most amazing
things i've seen like seriously like he
came in and it wasn't just because of
the fans the way he played and he really
took the nba over for
what two or three months yeah yeah um
and then the pressure came on and it was
harder because it was expectations on
him now now he wasn't just out there
just playing it was like okay now we
need to score 20 points every night yeah
and that's when pressure comes and it
becomes a little bit different for guys
yeah every every mistake you make
there's like a magnifying glass now yeah
yeah is it um
is it like the coach saying like now you
have to you have to perform this way if
you don't then we kind of have to move
you around and figure out a different
game player no i think it was more like
he was getting pressure from everybody
you know now he has the whole asian
community following him yeah when he
goes to taiwan i mean i've been there a
few times
it's like he is like michael jackson
over there
seriously it's like police escorts and
yeah they gotta block down city blocks
for him and stuff like that so
i think when you had that amount of
pressure on you you never was kind of
giving it and earning it at each stage
it just comes at you at one time that's
rough that's tough that's for anybody
anything they do in life if you're
getting all that pressure it's hard for
you to perform like that true
how did you go through it
mine came over time it's like little by
little little by little so for me it
wasn't like a big rush of attention that
just came all the sudden me um and i was
on losing teams we're getting my ass
kicked every night
i went from at michigan state when the
national championship my
freshman year went to the final four of
my sophomore year and then in the nba
i i mean we won 16 games out of 82. so i
was like what the hell this this sucks i
hate losing
so the attention for me was never always
constant it just came over time yeah
when did it when was like that pivotal
moment where it like it was a rush of it
i'll probably have to say the dunk
contest kind of did it a little bit yeah
um it's it was more in the bay area um
being the warriors because we were like
i said we sucked for so many years and
he was losing and it was like the only
bright sprite
bright spot for the warriors it's like
oh man we got something to cheer for
yeah that we believe yeah so the tension
came a little bit but
uh i'm a very humble guy i never big
time people if you want to talk to me
i'm always talking to kids i always sign
every autograph i mean my you know my
voice used to get mad like yo your
autograph never go worth anything i'm
like
why could you do it i do it so much i'm
like it's just an
you know i'm just so normal like that
it's like
it's who want to pay for my autographs
like so what just sign it you're so cool
you are definitely humble you're really
dope
um yeah like i mean i was reading so
much about you and that was one of the
things that's constantly said about you
how you're such a humble like you're a
class act and that that's why a lot of
people really like love you yeah i just
for me it was always um
when i was younger and i said if i ever
get famous i don't feel like just
because i do something really well that
i'm better than somebody i mean we all
are human we all put our parents on the
same time one leg at a time but some
people's pants are fancier than others
some people pants aren't with their
fancy though but you still got to put
one leg through at a time unless you got
some pants and somebody holding me
jumping in them yeah yeah that's what
kardashian's doing
but i just feel like we just you know if
everybody can understand and respect
each other and have that we could all
get along a lot better so
i felt like
why should i big-time somebody because i
do something pretty good you know god
gave me this ability to showcase it but
it's also
gave me to reach out to different people
and change people's lives maybe in a
sense if i talk to somebody um that's
cool yeah
that's beautiful yeah a lot of our
friends are from the bay area and
they're just like you're a god to them
and i still don't understand i'm sorry i
love the bay area fans i totally love
them but i'm like i didn't win a
championship
didn't make the all-star game i just
played hard and i just don't know i
think that's what it is yeah i think
that's what it is seriously yeah you
gave it your all and they noticed it and
i'm looking at it like you know i go
back there every now and then or
you know i go in the streets and
somebody know they're a go state fan i'm
like you guys got stuff clay draymond
they won championships you had kevin
durant those guys are all stars you
still like i'm your favorite warrior oh
that's great and i still haven't won
more than like 30 games
but it is so cool man it's just like
you know to have that that that feeling
for those fans and appreciation for my
career on her heart at work yeah you
know like um i think one thing that it's
hard for people to understand
uh but like
when you when you get to the top level
it's because you're competitive right
and you're a really good athlete so
that's like
a bucket that needs to be filled
obviously when you play professional
sports the financial side of things
that's another bucket
and i think like for people that haven't
been in it
they'll see like a boxer get knocked out
all the time or whatever i'll get
knocked out for like 10 million dollars
every single time i don't mind but the
the athlete the boxer is dying on the
inside they're like i want to win like i
want i won my first 100 boxing matches
so for you when you're in a period where
you played 80 games 1 30 you said right
like
i'm sure financially it was good because
you're in the in the pros
how does it like is there like this
weird thing that kind of pulls out your
heartstrings or does it feel weird to
like every time you're walking off the
court you're like this but then you walk
into like a lamborghini or something
like what is that dynamic you know it's
so funny because everybody says like you
know especially with pro athletes like
what where in the world do you have you
got all the the money in the world but
it ain't about that it's not about that
for a lot of us it's pride like
literally it's pride yeah yeah i got
money and i could take care of my family
and all this stuff like that but
i work so hard to win you know i want to
win a championship i want to be an
all-star so it's a pride factor and you
could tell which guys are pride factor
based and which guys are money based
like who like who let me know
i'm gonna give you some inside tips on
who how you can point them out okay okay
okay
the one the guy that don't come back
better the season after oh
thank you you have weaknesses in your
game and you don't come back you don't
you're not here for pride you're not
here to get better yeah um you're just
here for the job you're just here for
the job uh
the guy that just you know winning they
win the game or lose a game and it's it
doesn't matter to them
it's just there for the money so you
could you could spot those guys all and
as soon as i said i know a lot of people
bring up a lot of names like that
you're not talking about one specific
person
it's a type it's just it is with the nba
and that's one thing about you know you
talk about the superstars the steph
curry's lebrons the jordans the kobe's
those guys were like god gifted really
good
but what drove them because they wanted
to be the best ever yeah it's not even
about the money it's not even about the
money i mean those guys getting paid i
mean i think brian's worth almost a
billion dollars or something nike gave
him a billion dollars but in his mind
it's not about the money is i want to be
the best ever
like i don't everybody talk about jordan
this and co i'm going to be the best
ever so
those guys are are driven about becoming
the best ever so
you had those type of guys and then like
i said you had those type of guys that
just uh i got a paycheck yeah i mean
they play hard that's kind of in any
career right yeah you do have those
people that are passionate about their
craft that are there for it and they're
like non-stop eat breathe live it and
then there's the other people that are
just like trying to collect the checks
so i get it yeah i get it
going back to your first professional
game
like uh
because i don't think any of us and most
people oh there's only 400 people in the
nba you know so no one else is going to
understand yeah no one else understands
but what's what's it like in the day in
the life of a nba athlete because i've
seen like on mtv cribs that there's
special planes or some teams have
special places right
where the chairs are for tall people and
they have like a box of m m's and
skittles you can't get that on a regular
plane like what's like the day in the
life or even the day in the life of a
week a week in the life of uh
nba basketball we're spoiled i'm not
gonna lie we're spoiled but it's worse
now these guys oh my gosh okay how is it
in your time versus now okay so my time
we still have private planes we got
seven footers on our team we had the big
chairs and you know we had food and you
know just the normal stuff but these
guys man they get like four chefs they
like get fed eight times a day and i
mean it's get all this money and just
like
i mean it looks like all their locker
rooms are just like some of the locker
rooms have barber shops in them whoa and
college locker rooms have barbershops
wow
um just unlimited assets to recovery uh
state-of-the-art doctors um just
everything it's just it's totally
different now um these guys really treat
their bodies like temples like for me
like the first four or five years in the
nba we didn't have a nutritionist so
yeah you don't know anything yeah so
like right before the game i used to
have like two big macs
it was like i was a big mac guy i had to
have them like and this is like an hour
before the game started this is like
literally i'm walking around with a gut
full of mcdonald's hamburger does it
help you play better it was terrible it
was awful and then i didn't learn until
later on like maybe my sixth or seventh
year like that was why i was probably
playing it halfway slow because i
couldn't digest the terrible burgers
that was in me
but
with these guys now you start hearing a
lot of guys that are vegan you know they
see in the positive they really taking
their job seriously yeah as far as
what they feeling their body with and
how they're recovering and training for
it yeah that makes sense i mean back in
the day when they were wearing the short
shorts they were also in chucks yeah
imagine what their feet and their knees
must have felt like oh my gosh i mean
the short shorts are back but i don't
know about the chucks
yeah those are rough
do you guys have to go through like tsa
what's your guys's like flight process
you just go right to the plane and hop
on and go like on the tarmac
yeah yeah wow private plane section you
just go there boom hop on the plane you
go because you gotta think
we're always in there it's always
traveling like
this from game to game the game of the
game so like if baseball and football
for instance baseball players they play
a series in the city so if the
oakland a's are playing against the
minnesota twins
they're gonna be in that town for three
or four maybe five days and play three
or four five games whereas the nba team
we're in that town we play that game and
we're leaving going on to the next city
and so sometimes they don't do it as
much now this is why i say guys they're
we used spoiled
have four games and five nights on the
road whoa
like so you will play in the city
you i mean you're flying the city like
on a sunday you'll play monday
fly out the next day i mean fly out that
night
go to the next city the next morning
have breakfast get ready for that game
please are you on a uh red-eye you're
flying out on this line you're flying
right out you're not standing you gotta
go where are you sleeping on the plane
oh so yeah it's so it's so it's a tough
adjustment because your body is just
like man what is going on like this is
[ __ ] [ __ ]
like crash and so
i tell people all the time if you if
you're a serious basketball fan just
watch this process because the first
part of the season from october to
december the games are amazing because
guys are excited they're back in the
season hey let's play this play
around january to all-star break which
is like january to like right around
valentine's day it is the worst
basketball ever because guys are [ __ ]
tired they're like i can't wait to
all-star break i need a week off and the
games are bad and then after all-star
break when everybody refresh then the
games are good again
but it just it's a long process and this
is just a battle it's so it's really you
it's a it's more mental than anything
honestly is that why um some people that
might have been good at college break at
the pro level because of the it's you're
playing number one a higher level game
but number two there's press
there's the travel like the logistics
the behind the scenes of basketball
is not what you're used to in college
and it crushes you yeah it is it's some
of that is just
their skill set maybe not just as good
for the nba level as was in the college
but
um a lot of it has to do with um your
mentality because
you could have
you know argument with your wife or your
girlfriend um got in a car accident
get to the arena your favorite
pair of shoes is missing but you got
going to court before because nobody
cares yeah
we don't care what happened we just know
you on this floor so
a lot of people don't understand that
aspect that even though we're
professional athletes and we get paid
millions of dollars to do this we're
still human yeah so we still have days
where it's just like god damn i don't
want to do [ __ ] today yeah but we still
have to go perform because that's our
job yeah wow that's tough yeah
do you think that has um
playing like
such a a high-paced professional sport
do you think that has
rubbed off in your personal life in any
way and
um right now that
you don't play at like such a high-paced
level um do you feel like you missed it
at all
you know what i don't miss it at all um
the thing i missed when and you could
talk to any retired player we missed the
camaraderie we missed being around the
guys we missed you know the locker room
banner and and
just the dinners and stuff like that you
don't miss playing like that is a grind
it is like a tiring grind so
uh you just miss being around the guys i
think that's the biggest thing that a
lot of athletes have a hard time leaving
behind is just being around the guys
just the stuff off the court because
it's so many stories you have and the
fun times and stuff like that
i see yeah speaking about how like you
know like the spoiled baseball players
they get to like
you know rest like a good three four
days while you guys are
serious would you say like baseball
players are kind of weak
no
why you trying to get them in trouble i
have baseball friends
well i think those guys are lucky i mean
you look at all the pitchers those guys
might pitch 17 yeah they get wrecked and
they they just i mean it's a lot on
their shoulders
but
man i would love to play only 17 games a
year yeah that's it right and get paid
like 25 million dollars a year for 17
games
but i mean it's pretty cool though i
mean
if you were to put in the hierarchy of
like professional sports which one do
you think is
the toughest
and then which one do you think is like
the best that's the well like i don't
know that's
that's the idea like i want to do that
but the toughest is i mean i don't well
if you say major sports i mean yeah
that's like soccer baseball basketball
football football
um football players it's i just don't
know how they do it because they're just
getting slammed everybody's getting
slammed and at any given moment one
injury could be career entering and yeah
that's it it's like semi trucks just
like crashing into each other and then
if you get hurt like that they could
just cut you and you don't get paid it's
just like i just don't understand how
their player association doesn't fight
that more like yeah those guys get
abused so much
um so they're probably like they're the
hardest yeah
i'm gonna say hockey players second
because i think they get underpaid just
like football players and they just
wrecking their bodies also
um basketball players and then probably
baseball players they're they're like
yeah they're like kind of like they got
the cheerleaders a little bit yeah they
got the easy job i mean it's hard
i played baseball but
there's not a lot of physical movement
going on in baseball they don't have to
do a lot of running i mean you hit a
ball and they get spread you got to
sprint but
literally how many times you go to
sprint yeah i mean you get more
strikeouts or more
fly balls than anything so i remember uh
so when i went to ucla there's a stadium
on the side drake stadium where like you
know it's open to the public yeah so
people run the bleachers and i would go
and then just run bleachers and just do
laps and i would see the baseball team
train
there i've never seen baseball players
train before and i was legit watching
these guys doing like a five yard sprint
i know there's skill in the game right
and i'm just like you know when the
ball's coming at you at like 90 miles
per hour it's hard to hit it with the
bat i get it there's a lot of skill but
i'm like
running from here to here
and then and then going
like oh man i'm like i should have tried
out for baseball
you sound like a hater
they don't look i mean so i played
basketball for a little bit okay i uh i
i used to wrestle in high school i went
and in my junior year i went to uh this
military school in san diego
and
my weight class dude was the state champ
and then i was a junior year in high
school so i wasn't about to beat jv you
know i'm like he's taking four i'm not
bjv and i played a lot of like street
ball so like i'm athletic i can move
around so i tried out for the basketball
team
and you know running suicides and stuff
like that that's like i'm like this is a
real sport yeah running like from here
to here i'm like
i don't know about that
[Laughter]
what um
so now that you're
you're uh
you know like i still see that you're
playing in like all these golf
tournaments and stuff like that like
what is the life
post professional sports well it's a lot
of traveling with my kids they into a
youth sports and it's just constantly
travel but um
i play a lot of golf i'm an avid golfer
i think that's have you played that
before like just in high school too yeah
my dad taught it to me when i was
younger but playing so many multiple
sports that were high fast and i mean
this motion and movement i was like man
this sucks like i just want to drive the
cart and like to this day i regret that
to this day because i think my golf game
be a lot more better than what it is
right now yeah if i stuck with it when i
was younger
but i mean it is what it is and it gives
my competitive edge out of me because
you know one little thing in golf could
go wrong and it throws your whole game
off so you have to be really mentally
tough to play golf and um i just love
being outdoors and i'm out there with
music on i'm not like one of those
uptight golfers i'm music on cigars and
i'm drinking
so i'm gonna have a good time but at the
same time it's gonna be i want to go out
there and play good does it matter if
you're young or old you're going to beat
them yes you play that competitively
um i haven't played competitively yet um
i'm trying to get my golf game up there
um i'm pretty good but everyone's like
you should do it it's like no i'm a
perfectionist i was like i'm not there
yet so i like to make sure my game is
there before i do it but you think you
could do that at a professional level
not a professional level but they have a
lot of celebrity events and stuff like
that
and a lot of guys like you're better
than a lot of these celebrities i'm like
uh
i want to be the best and i'm not ready
that's just how competitive about
yourself you're really convinced oh yeah
so uh we're almost out of time so i want
to end uh we're almost out of time so i
want to end it on on this question
you know when when
when people are very competitive right
and they're confident and like this is
they have a lot of drive
naturally
they're
they're attracted to a spouse that's the
same way
when it's at home
and
both of you guys are a hundred percent
on your guys's position but you guys
that disagree
how do you guys resolve it
somebody had to walk away
oh really yeah
my wife uh she played college basketball
also uh i had to bring the story up
since she said competitiveness
um you know she's really prissy she's
really girly looking and she's like yeah
i play college basketball like yeah
she's fire though
just meeting her off the bat she is a
fire yes
and so she's like i play basketball so
he goes to a 24-hour fitness that's when
you guys first start dating first
started dating and you know i said hey
i'll play a game of five and i'm in the
nba um i think my s oh it's my first
year we made my first year a game to
five to ten the game to five and cause
i'm thinking like she there's no way
this girl play basketball i i mean i met
her she had a nice dress on like hill
she doesn't look like most girls that
play basketball are a little tough
she doesn't look that way sporty
yeah but she doesn't look that way and
so she gets the ball and i back off her
she hit a jumper i was like a lucky shot
she gets the ball again
hit a jumper she's like are you going to
play me i say yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah i'm playing you
so i said okay she's getting a little
competitive she got lucky here two shots
in a row so i get up on her and she's
pump fakes me driving around get the
basket i said oh no
so it's 3-0 now so i'll say okay it's
time to play
long story short the game became 4-4
she gets the ball and you let it get to
four to four yes because i didn't take
her seriously this is underestimated now
i was wrong for that i know now okay
we'll let it slide we'll let it slide
she gets the ball and she makes this
move on me
and i'm a sort of loser too look
[Laughter]
she got around me and i stuck my leg out
that's just the time
and it hit her then her thighs she got a
dead dead leg later yeah and foster
ground crying i picked up the ball and
go score
did that come back and like oh are you
okay
it's broken it's broken
she just had a big old bruise on her leg
so good um we were competitive like that
i think for us we both just go go go
cause she played ball i play ball she
coach kids
and she knows basketball just like
anybody else yeah i saw her just even
handled the ball yesterday and i'm like
oh she plays basketball i just see her
durable you know yeah wow so when you
get to that level i think it's some
argument because we both compared it
like i'm going to win argument but she's
smarter than me so she's going to win
and so i just all i do is leave because
i know that she outsmart me she's super
intelligent she's like electrical
engineer applied mathematics degrees
yeah and i'm still working on mine so
it's like yeah you got this one she's
really good at numbers yeah
if she played her kids one-on-one who's
winning
she doesn't do it anymore she became i
don't know what happened i think we got
too old like now she's like ah she's
like get girly on me oh she just want to
get physical oh and she used to be like
that she's to be so physical but we used
to have a lot of backyard two and twos
when we were in denver we you know oh
that sounds so fun no no because the
neighbors would have to call the police
like because our all we are a family of
four we are super ultra competitive just
talking [ __ ] and so
[ __ ] talking so one day i don't know how
they managed the boys they were this is
two years ago so they were 12 and 14.
they managed to
to you know hey we play a game with you
know two on two you and dad i mean your
mom versus me and jason jackson and
jason for iphone
they get a iphone you know iphones are
pretty expensive
yeah i don't know how they we got
bamboozled playing this game
but we started off that's your
competitive side because you're like how
are you gonna beat me i got this in the
bag that's probably what happened it was
it was friendly at first until we
started getting close to 12. it was
going to 12.
and it was arguments amongst teammates
me and my wife was arguing like you're
not boxing out you're not passing the
ball
on each other two kids started to argue
it and it's loud like i know our
neighbors are like this family is crazy
like i mean it was pure all arguments
don't do your [ __ ] job
long story short my sons hit some lucky
shots and we and we had to pay iphones
that sucks oh that was so mad we lost
and we had to get my phones
you and your wife are playing 100
we were yes we were almost there because
like we were competitive we don't like
to lose it so i don't think we talked to
each other like two hours after that it
was pretty bad she didn't do her job i
got mad
she started like she's like wait a
minute they're getting too big like yeah
i was like no we about to have to pay
two grand in iphones like seriously come
on
at 12 and 14 were they uh
like over six feet already they were i
think my oldest was just at six feet and
the youngest is like five nine ish
but the younger one he's obviously
bigger than the the bigger brother he's
six three and a half almost six four
then my oldest one now it's like six
three wow
yeah damn you guys got beat by kids
it sucks
i still remember i hate it every moment
oh man next time we see your kids we're
going to give them dabs yeah like can i
see that iphone right
what what were they supposed to give up
if you guys won
oh it was just only a one-sided no it
wasn't it was something like they had to
do chores for like a whole month it was
something bigger i can't remember what
it was yeah but their minds are focused
like bringing this iphone and like my
youngest son is the craziest thing
he just he was throwing up some crazy
just like behind the back shots and they
were going in it was like meant for them
to get an
iphone how the hell do you make that
have you even been practicing no
do that in a game where it counts
like it was maybe meant for them to get
an iphone i guess oh that's cool
well thank you so much jason it was so
fun no problem thank you for having me
and thank you for answering my stupid
question
because i'm always interested in stuff
like this you know like is there
anything you want to plug any place they
can follow any things that you're a part
of no my social media is boring
it's really boring it's golf and a
couple of highlights with my kids that's
about it yeah then just follow me then
again
and i'll see you guys next time peace